Dylan it's fabulous to be here with you
today thank you so much yeah thank you
so let's start at the very beginning how
did you get so into gaming yeah it's a
funny story I mean obviously fortnite
kind of came out took over like the
World by storm and all of my friends in
college we all started just like playing
and and really got into it I graduated
became a nurse I was first in the trauma
ICU and then when Co came around I was
switched into the co ICU I started to
get like a little bit burn out after
like 6 seven months of that I had been
doing fortnite on the side just as a
little hobby kind of thing it really
kind of transitioned though from like
gaming and like the gamer sense to like
more of the like creating sense when
they released their like creative
platform in you know 2018 and that's
where I kind of like picked up doing
more of the creative and development
side of things cuz more interesting to
me and it was very simple at the time so
I was able to like kind of pick things
up slowly and teach myself how you know
how to make a game a legend legendary
YouTube gamer named Alia he messaged me
and he was like Hey like your stuff
would you help me develop games so that
was kind of like the signal that I
needed to like fully jump into this and
after about 3 4 months of just doing it
full-time I started to like be able to
identify like where players would want
to play and it led me to want to create
like something bigger and that's kind of
how led to me forming a company and
trying to trying to grow that way now
talk to me about your new company and
what you're doing yeah so it's called
good Gamers the idea behind it is like
we wanted to approach the development
side of games from like a more of like a
marketing and and organization focused
so we have good Gamers and those are our
marketing and influencers and content
creators and we bring them into the team
because they are the people who can
reach a lot of people but then on the
back end we have you know people like me
and a couple others that I've brought on
who developed the good games
I want to get a sense of the the scale
of your business are you able to talk to
me about users or customers or anything
of that sort yeah since we can't sell
anything we don't have customers yet but
we have we have plenty of users the game
go goed that one reaches between 800,000
and a million players every day and has
over 750 million plays total and then
for our team we launched like six or 7
months ago and we already have I think
four games that are totaling over
500,000 players a day w so we've we've
reached over 100 million unique players
since I started in 20 like early 2020
and you've taken on no outside funding
correct not yet no how has that been
then building a business just
bootstrapping it yeah it's it's been
interesting I mean I I'm very blessed to
have the game that I have go goed and
that one has hovered you know as one of
the top games for a while and so it has
been able to fund like these ideas that
I I've wanted to kind of implement and
just I'm lucky to be able to do that
with you know what what I have know some
of the things I hear from the older
generation doesn't doesn't quite
understand you know the gaming space is
that you know this is just a hobby this
is not a career and I'm sure you've
probably heard that from a lot of people
in your life how have you dealt with
that and do you have any any advice for
people in the gaming industry who are
dealing with that that's a good question
I mean it is a hobby for a lot of people
but I think just like with so many
hobbies like if you are passionate about
something and you are you know a little
bit Savvy like you can turn a hobby or a
passion or whatever into a business for
yourself so I mean my answer to that
would be like this space has hundreds of
millions of people playing like every
year every day millions and millions of
players and it's constantly growing so
it can be more than a hobby if you want
it to be yeah and last one for you it's
really hard to go from just being a a
nurse to then taking the dive into
entrepreneurship what advice would you
have for people facing similar
situations there's a point that you get
to where you're like I think this is the
right thing to do this is something that
I believe in and your kind of like fear
or your fear of the unknown is like
holding you back so it kind of is just
like that point where I'm going to
commit to something and I'm I'm not
going to look back and for me that was
when I decided I'm not going to renew my
nursing license I'm going to just commit
to what I'm doing and I'm going to give
it my all just like be confident in
yourself and then you just have to take
that leap of faith and commit to it and
good things can come from
[Music]
that